as the pandemic worsens many americans
are also facing a desperate economic
plight but
congress has been at a stalemate for
months over a relief bill
nancy cordes is on capitol hill nancy
key protections for millions are due to
expire
by the end of the month is there any
progress at all
there is now anthony this bipartisan
group of senators about eight to ten of
them who are trying to revive
negotiations
and come up with some kind of stimulus
deal before the holidays but
i have to tell you it is a very tall
order they would have to figure out a
way to bridge the gap
between the 500 billion dollar package
that senate republicans want
and the 2 trillion dollars that house
democrats have proposed
now on capitol hill today federal
reserve chair jerome powell is going to
testify that the pace of
economic recovery since pandemic
lockdowns
has moderated it has slowed that's why
this is such a critical
debate and treasury secretary steven
mnuchin is also going to testify he's
going to urge congress
to pass a bipartisan bill to distribute
about 450 billion dollars
in unused funds from the march cares act
now a bill that size might include more
funding for business loans and grants
but it probably wouldn't include
another round of stimulus checks or a
boost in unemployment insurance that is
something that is very important
to democrats but on the senate floor
yesterday the republican leader mitch
mcconnell urged democrats
to take what they can get at this point
he argued essentially that half a loaf
is better than no loaf at all tony all
right nancy thank you very much